Good afternoon, everyone. Thanks so much for joining us today.
I'm Nas Zahir. I'm the Acting Director of the Center for Cancer Training at the
National Cancer Institute,
and I want to welcome you to our NCI-sponsored session on
opportunities to support early career cancer researchers and research
specialists.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
And the NCI supports multiple career pathways for
cancer researchers. Our session here is for students,
postdocs, and scientists
who are ready to explore NCI's training and career development opportunities.
For everyone on the panel, can I see a show of hands?
How many are graduate students in the room?
Nice.
Postdocs?
Okay. Any undergraduate students?
One. Welcome.
Any mentors, faculty?
Administrators?
Awesome. All right. Welcome. So we're going to talk about intramural
research, training at the NCI, extramural funding, and tips for
successful applications.
And first, we'll start off with Chanelle Case Borden, who will talk about training
at NCI.
And then for extramural funding opportunities, Mark D'Amico will talk
about fellowships. Susan Lim will talk about career development
awards. And then we'll also talk about research specialist
awards, which are our R50 program.
This will be Kelly Crotty talking about research specialist awards.
And then clinical scientist awards to be presented by Wolf
Lindwasser at the NCI. So I hope you enjoy the
session. We will also have time for questions at the end,
so please stay and participate in the Q&A at the
end of our session. Thanks so much.
Next is Chanelle Borden.
Okay. Thank you, Nas. So today, I'll be talking about training
opportunities within the NCI Intramural Research Program.
And I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So, a little bit about the IRP, or the Intramural Research Program.
It is comprised of scientists, physicians, and clinicians, and not mentioned are
all the administrators and other staff that keep the IRP running.
We are located in the NCI offices and laboratories in
Maryland, as well as the NIH Clinical Center.
And we conduct basic, clinical, genomic, and population-based
research. And today, I'm going to talk a little bit more about that, and then also
end with how you can join us if you're interested in training at NCI.
So, we get this question a lot, and a lot of people wonder where we are
actually located when they're looking for summer internships or fellowships.
And we are located in Maryland. So there are actually three campuses
across Maryland within 20 to 25 minutes away from each other, and
that's the NIH Bethesda Campus, which you see the NIH Clinical
Center in the middle. You have the NCI Shady Grove Campus, and then about
20 minutes up the road and up 270 is the NCI
Frederick Campus. And across those three campuses, we have over
200 principal investigators and over 800 fellows in all of
those different research groups.
So, what do we do? So we conduct cancer research with
a purpose, similar to the extramural funding.
We actually conduct
research across the cancer continuum as well.
So we pursue high-risk, high-reward research that is unlikely to be
traditionally funded. So that's going to be things that don't have
clear clinical applications up front or things that
take a longer time. We can tackle those kinds of difficult
problems. We also support research that benefits small numbers
or underserved patients. So think your rare cancers or
certain minority groups. And then we also address emergent
public health issues or threats.
So that allows us to be able to really conduct the full
scope of cancer care. And our research areas
run along those very similar lines.
So everything from basic translational clinical work through
bioinformatics, biostatistics, cancer prevention, cancer
control, global health, and population science.
So all of those research areas are actually housed across a
number of divisions, offices, and centers, and those are the ones that are spread
out across those three campuses. So the Intramural Research
Program traditionally consists of the Center for Cancer Research, or CCR,
and the Division of Cancer Epidemiology and Genetics, or DCEG.
So you will find almost 90% of our fellows within those two
divisions, with majority of them in the Center for Cancer Research.
However, there are limited opportunities to train within the Division of
Cancer Control and Population Science, as well as the Center for Global
Health.
Our last two divisions here, the Center to Reduce Cancer Health Disparities, as
well as the Division of Cancer Prevention, host specific
training fellowship programs, which allow their fellows to then train in
those other four divisions as well.
So there are a lot of opportunities in those different research areas.
And across all of those divisions, we strive to attract,
train, and retain the best minds to become the next generation of cancer
researchers. So at the
NCI, you will find undergraduates, post-bacs, graduate students,
medical students,
postdocs, as well as
research fellows and clinical research fellows within our training programs.
And our research environment is one that is really second to none in
terms of the quality of scientific training and mentoring.
We are a highly collaborative institution with lots of
opportunities to work with multidisciplinary teams and partner with scientists
across the world. So this is one of those
questions that we got a lot during the career fair yesterday, was like, "Okay, is
it similar to academia?" And I
came to NCI as a graduate student, so I have limited experience of what it's like
in academia. But from what I recall, it was pretty similar, except you
get to add on those added benefits of those extra resources and those
levels of collaboration.In addition to that, we
also have world-class technology with access to over 40 cores,
and we really are committed to preparing
our fellows for their next education or career goal.
So here in the Center for Cancer Training, we oversee a lot of
the different career and professional development opportunities, as well
as recruitment opportunities.
And one of the, I think, really unique structures to the training environment is
that there is so much support for our fellows here on campus.
So starting within those individual divisions, offices, and centers, there are
training staff, training directors. I'll show a picture of some of them later.
Two of them are in our audience.
And there is a lot of support at that level.
But our office, together with the NIH Office of Training and Education
or OITE, which you may be familiar with, we host a number
of career workshops and trainings that are offered across
those core competencies, such as career exploration,
communication, leadership and management, mentoring and teaching, as
well as wellness.
So I did want to add a little bit, touch on the logistics of being an
NCI intern or a fellow, because these are some common questions that we often get
asked. All of our positions are paid internships or fellowships.
We are unable to provide housing with any of those, but we do point you in the
direction of helpful resources to help you identify if you have to relocate
to Maryland.
Our public transportation, like the Metro, the bus, is
subsidized or parking is provided if that is something that you are interested
in. And I think one of the crucial things that we remind all of our
applicants is that you must be able to pass a federal background check in order to
participate in the IRP.
I can't talk too much about eligibility because it will vary by education
stage or program. So I highly encourage you to look up the program or
division that you're interested in working in.
But just know that there is some variation between the citizen requirements or
enrollment or time since most recent degree.
So you just really want to make sure you're paying attention to that.
And one of the things that I wanted to mention is that we have recently
developed the Train at NCI application portal.
And it's a website that is designed to really help you navigate how to figure
out what type of internship or fellowship you might be interested
in. So you can scan a QR code or visit
trainatnci.cancer.gov to view a lot of our training
opportunities and just learn more about the kind of research that we do.
And if you're interested in joining us, there are four core ways that you
can join the Intramural Research Program.
The first is to contact investigators directly.
That gets a little complicated now.
You can apply to central NCI or NIH databases.
You submit your CV or application materials, and then you would contact
investigators to encourage them to look at your materials.
You can also explore open fellowship positions.
I think this is the best way to be able to navigate trying
to find a post-bac or post-doc, or you can apply to a cohort
training program. And I wanted to leave you with talking a little bit about the
cohort training programs.
So the first is the summer
program, so the Cancer Research Interns program.
So this is an up to 12-week
full-time research opportunity.
And with the CRI program, it gives you the opportunity to receive
additional mentorship as well as professional development support.
It is open to undergrads, graduate students, and medical students.
And you don't need to have previous research experience.
However, it is helpful, but it is not a requirement.
The applications for the summer typically open in mid-November
with the applications closing for CRI in January, as with the
general summer internship program typically closes in February.
The next program I wanted to talk about was the Intramural Continuing Umbrella
Research Experiences, or ICURE program.
And that is
currently for post-bac and post-doc research experiences.
You have the opportunity to spend up to two to three years conducting research
on-site at NCI. The start date is
the September following the application cycle.
So, for example, the application just closed for this year's
cohort, but it won't start until September of next year.
It provides multi-level mentorship and career development
support, as well as connection to the extensive CURE network as well.
So the applications for the next cycle will open this fall.
And lastly, we have the Cancer Prevention Fellowship Program or CPFP.
So that is a post-doc research experience that is mentored and multidisciplinary
and really focused on providing specialized training in
epidemiology and biostatistics.
And it gives up to four years conducting full-time research on-site with
additional coaching and career development support as well.
So those applications typically open in May and close in
September. So the sites currently are not updated yet, but they should be within
the next couple of weeks. So you can be on the lookout for that one.
I think no matter what,
one of the best resources that we have at NCI really is our
training directors. And if you know what research area you're
interested in, I just highly encourage you to contact them and
learn more about their respective divisions or any opportunities that they may
have. They're very wonderful people and always willing to
help.
And if you have any questions, you can also contact me as well.
You can visit us at the Train at NCI to learn more about our research and our
programs or join our Listserv to stay up to date on upcoming training
opportunities. And with that, thank you very
much.
Hi.
Welcome. My name is Mark D'Amico. I'm a program officer at
NCI at the Center for Cancer Training,
and I'm going to talk a little bit today about NCI fellowship training
opportunities that you can all apply for.
This is my disclosure information. I work for the federal government.
I have no money.
This graphic here shows sort of
the
mechanisms that we offer at the Center for
Cancer Training,
grouped by career stage. And since we're
talking here about fellowships,
we're going to be talking
exclusively about those mechanisms on the far
left, the predoctoral fellowships, the F30, the
F31, and the F99K00.
This is a look at our funding page.
You can find lots of helpful information on all of the
different mechanisms that we offer,
and you can see those on the left side of the screen.
You would want to click on whichever one you're looking for or that you're
interested in. You'll be taken to a separate page, which will give you
information on eligibility,
what types of funding levels you could expect,
and as well as things like contact information for the people you
want to talk to
as soon as possible.
So the Ruth Kirschstein National Research Service Award fellowships are
individual fellowships.
They are for PhD research
candidates and for dual degree research candidates.
The PhD research candidates would apply for the
F31 predoc.
These are for candidates who have achieved candidacy for their degree,
and they are performing their dissertation research.
The F31 provides up to five years of support,
and it provides you a stipend, plus money for
tuition and fees, plus an annual training
expenses
fund of about $4,750
that your institutions can use to pay for things like health
insurance
and for other types of things. The F30 is for, as
I said, dual degree candidates. These, we at
NCI, we support you during your clinical and graduate
training for any combined doctoral degree.
That would be an MD PhD or a veterinary PhD, for example.
But all of the
types of dual degrees that we
support can be found in each individual NOFO.
In order to apply for the F30, you have to be within
48 months of matriculation into an accredited
dual degree program,
and that's for your initial application, what we call an A0
application. Once you have made that application, your
resubmission, should you need it, is free.
So you don't need to worry about the 48-month rule after that.
If, for example,
you put in an application extremely early in your career,
and you are not funded, and you are not funded again in your resubmission,
you can still put in another A0 application as
long as you meet the 48-month rule requirement.
So that almost never happens, but I can't say never.
The F30 provides up to six years of support, and that
also, as with the F31, is for a stipend
plus tuition and fees, which is the big thing,
plus training related
expenses,
as with the F30. I'm sorry, as with the F31.
We take applications from people who are doing
cancer-focused research. Once we
figure that you're doing cancer-focused research, your application will go to
review.
You
do not need to be a US citizen or a green card holder
in order to apply. However, you do need to be one of those two
things if you do get the award.
For all fellowships, NCI will give funding opportunity to
applications that indicate that funds are available to support the
candidate's research training plan throughout the duration of the award.
That is, does your mentor have money to support you?
You are getting a stipend, but you're not getting a whole lot of money to do
research. That stuff is going to have to come from somewhere else.
And also to applications where the proposed scientific
research is distinct from the mentor's pending or active
grants.
We do not want to see substantial text duplication of your mentor's
specific aims. That's something that we talk about
all the time, and while we all don't like it, some of us
hate it more than others.
So some of the important dates that you're going to want to keep in mind.
There are three receipt cycles every year for the fellowships,
the F30 and F31. There are three receipt dates, as I said, April
8th, August 8th, and December 8th of any individual calendar
year.
For the April 8th deadline,
your initial review will take place sometime in June or July.
There will be a review, a secondary review.
The council, the NCAB council, usually will convene
in September or October. The earliest possible start date
for yourfor your F is in
December of that same year. So you're going to want to think about this in terms
of how long you're going to be a graduate student
and not only how much time you have
left, but how much you need the funds. So everybody is different.
Everybody has to weigh that for themselves.
The same things apply for the August 8th and December 8th deadlines.
It takes a good eight months or so before you're going to get funded.
If you are
funded and you decide that you want to change your start date, you can do
that. You just need to contact us and say, "Mark, I
don't want to start with the start date I
chose. Can I start later?" Yes, you can.
You can start as much as six months later than your chosen start date, and
we do that
all the time. And again, that's all individual.
Everybody has their own needs.
There are new review criteria for the Fs.
All applications submitted on or after January 25th,
2025, they'll be reviewed using a simplified review
criteria. You can find those review criteria at the
linky here.
Remember now that scholastic performance grades are not
permitted in your fellowship applications any longer, so you're going to want
to think about that as well.
Application updates. Use these links and these
QR codes to find helpful information and resources
on how to make your application. The other resource for making your
application is us, your program officers.
Please contact us early and often.
That's what we're here for. We can't help you until you ask us.
So for the individual predoctoral and postdoctoral transition award, the
F99-K00, these are for people in the third or
fourth year of graduate school.
The F99 portion is for the predoc portion, and the
K00 is for after you become a doctor.
It's nice because
you can go to
somewhere you want to postdoc with and say, "Look, I have funds for my
own research." That makes you much more
attractive than people who have no money, which is pretty much the same
thing you'll find anywhere. So again, it's for the third and fourth year
health-related PhD students. You must be a US citizen or permanent
resident.
One or two years of support will come for the F99.
You will get a stipend, tuition, and training-related expenses at
NRSA levels. And for the K00 portion,
you get up to four years of support for postdoc training at a US
institution, and you will receive salary and
annual increases at levels greater than
normal NRSA levels.
So things you want to consider before you apply.
First of all, you should be reading the funding opportunity, what we call a NOFO,
and the SF424. That is basically the
how-to-apply thing.
Once you've read it, please read it again.
It's important that you know exactly what you're supposed to be doing in your
application so that you do not fall into some of the potholes.
Check your eligibility.
The eligibility for the Fs are pretty much the same across the board,
but any time in the future when you're applying for a
grant at NCI or a funding opportunity at NCI,
the eligibility rules are different for every mechanism.
So please check those all the time. Make sure you're eligible.
If you still have a question,
program officers are waiting for your call.
Talk with your mentor. Make sure that you guys are on the same page,
that you know exactly what this research is going to be about, how you're going to
do it, how you're going to do it if it doesn't work, because it never does.
All of the things that you should take into consideration when you start a research
plan. And again, plan ahead.
Use your program officers for everything that you
need. Okay? We're here to answer your questions, to guide
you through the process, to help you get funded, and to help you begin your
career.
Contact us, as I said earlier, early and often.
Now, a little bit of self-promotion.
I will be giving a Meet the Expert talk at the NCI booth, number
736,
on Tuesday at noon on the Loan Repayment Program.
A lot of you guys are going to want to know about the Loan Repayment Program.
If you have questions about that, please come and see me.
Come and sit and watch me talk and
I can answer questions about the LRP because apparently I am the
liaison for NCI with the LRP.
Contact information for us now is done by sort
of mailboxes rather than individual program officers.
If you have questions or want to contact your program officer,
each mechanism has its own mailbox.
We all read all of the emails that come into the
mailbox for which we are
responsible. We are actually expected by our boss
to answer the emails that we get. So we will answer
you in a day or two, unless we're here at a place like
this and we don't have access. But there's always somebody who's going to answer
your question right away. We know that the last thing you want is
to have a question that you really need
answered and nobody answers you.
So I just want to thank you guys for your attention.
And our next speaker will be Susan Lim, and she's going to talk
about the T32.
Here you go.
Hi, I'm Susan. I'm with the Cancer Training Branch,
and today I'm going to be talking about Career Development
Award.
So I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So you've seen this
infograph. So at Cancer Training Branch, we have funding
opportunities for different career stages.
And you just heard Mark D'Amico talk about the fellowship
targeted for the pre-doc
trainee. So I'm going to be focusing on the early career
stage
applicants, which is a post-doc,
instructors in some cases, and then assistant
professor for the K08. So this is a K
mechanism, and then we have a institutional training
grant,
which is K12,
R25, and T32.
This is applied by the established investigator.
So,
what are the Mentored Career Development Award? We call this a K's.
At NCI, K is Mentored Career Development Awards,
share the
common goal of preparing investigators or applicants for independent
cancer-focused research careers, but they are different
substantially in applicant background and
research focus, and career trajectory.
It provides protected time to do research.
We will give you a salary support and
research-related expenses.
The clock is now running.
Okay. So,
currently we have
five different K awards. It's a K01, K08,
K25, and then we have one, the K32, which is
very
NCI-specific
application. It's still pending, so it's not active yet.
And then we have a transitional award, which is a
K99-R00. We have two of them. So the following
slides, we will be talking more detail about these
mechanism.
So here, this is a comparison between those three
K mechanism, K01, K08, and
K25. They all are Mentored Career Development Award,
and they require US citizen or permanent residency
at the time of the award. If you don't have that status, even though you
have a perfect score, you will not get the award.
So these are eligibility requirement you have.
So K01 and all these mechanism need a doctorate
degree. So K01, you need a PhD or equivalent doctorate.
K08, you need to have a clinical degree.
If you have a PhD, but your job or your
career is with a clinical duty, so if you can get a
PhD in nursing, but then you deal with a
patient, so that's allowed. So K25
is you have a PhD or equivalent doctorate degree, but then
your training is in quantitative.
So you could be engineer, you could be a computer scientist,
but then you want to bring your
expertise or training into a cancer
biology, so you can apply under K25.
So these are
all early career stage prior to associate professor level
for K08. K25 allows some of the
established PI to apply for the K25 because you are
changing your research focus disciplinary.
So K01, you don't need clinical license.
K08, you do need clinical license.
K25, you don't need clinical license.
So what are the research focus? So K01, we allowed all the
cancer-related research, but K01, we give
priority to area of cancer
control and population science and cancer prevention.
K08 is you are clinicians, that's a must, and
then you can do all sorts of cancer research, which is basic,
translation, patient-oriented research.
And then K25, is your background has to be
computational, bioengineering, data science, but then you
are focusing on cancer research. So you are
required to have 75% research effort committed to
the
award.
K08, if you are a surgeon, we allow you to reduce to
50% of the research effort because
we want you to maintain your clinical skill set.
What we give as support. We give you up to 100,000 in
salary for under K01 and K25. But
K08, we give you up to 228, which is a legislative cap,
which increase every year. So current is
$228,000.
And then we provide 50,000
towards your research-related expenses per year.
And the award is for three to five years.
So, the
pending mechanism, K32, which is
we require you have to have a less than two years of
post-doctoral experiences. We give you up to
80,000 in salary, towards your salary, 30,000 for
research development, and it is three years award only.
And again, this one also require you have to be US citizen or
permanent residency at the time of the award.
One unique thing about the K32 is once you have the award for three
years, you are still eligible to apply for the other
K award.So we hope that
the announcement NOFO will be published next month,
and then we will start
receiving the application in June.
But this is what we hope, but we will see what's going to happen.
So,
the
last set of K mechanism is K99-R00.
We call it is a Pathway to for Independence, or we also
call as a Transition Award. Again, it is to help
post doctors research complete the needed and mentor career development,
and transition to a timely manner to independent tenure
track or equivalent faculty positions to develop
for innovative and independent research career that will be
competitive for subsequent independent funding, which mean R01.
So this mechanism is the only one that we allow
non-citizen
applicants at the domestic institutions.
It has to be in the US institution you're applying for.
So we have a two different type. One require less than two years of post-doctorate
experience, and the other one is less than six years of
post-doctorate
research experience. So the applicant must not
held a independent faculty position or tenure track position
at the time of the application.
So here is a comparison. So this is the Early
K99-R00, and this is a Regular Parents, we call
it K99-R00. So this is for
early stage
investigators with less than two years of post-doctorate research
experience at the time of the application.
And then the K99 is less than six years.
So Early K99 priorities in cancer
data science, cancer control science, molecular precision
cancer prevention, and other fields, only if clearly ready for
independence with the two years of mentoring experience.
And the other K99 is open to all area of cancer
research. So because of this is require only two years
of post-doctorate experiences, we might not need that
much of a preliminary data or publication.
But then the other standard K99 is
very competitive award.
So next slide. So this is a infographic for what
this transition
award is for. So we give you up to two years at
the post-doctorate. So once you get the award,
you have two years of K99 portion. At that time, you have to start applying
for tenure track position. So once you get the tenure track position
right here, then you activate the R00
part. So if you don't find
tenure track position within the K99 part, then
you will not get the R00. So R00 is activated only at
the tenure track position institution.
It is competitive because you give you
$100,000 for during K99 mentor phase
training. Then when you get in tenure track, we give
you up to $249,000 per year for
independent research. So that's why it's very attractive, and yet it is also
very competitive award. So next slide.
This is show you the
last three years of our funding rate or success rate,
whichever you call it. So K01, 2025
was the first year that we started the program for the
NCI. So this is nine awards out of 32
application. It's a 28% funding rate.
Then K08, the last three years, it's around
20%. But last year is a very interesting year and
challenging year. So we
were unable to award as many as we
done before. So
K25,
we have a smaller applicant pool, so two out of six
in 2023. In 2024, we
only have one application, and that application did well, so we fund it, so it's
100%.
And last year, out of 10 application, we fund, so
20%. So here is bottom is the Transition Award, Early
K99-R00. So we have an average of
24% success rate. And then
K99-R00, the application increasing
as every year. So we have a 13% to 16%
success rate.
So the next slide. This slide is just to show you a brief of characteristic
of
our K awards. So the red bar is the K08,
which is clinician scientists, and the blue and green is for
K99. So
just focus on the bottom. So at fiscal year
2024, 100% of the awardees are PhDs,
okay? So this is what we expected. And 85%
of K08
awardees are MD or MD PhD, and 15% are
PhD in clinical science. So
here,
this is the first author publication.
So 19%
of the K08 awardees have a one to five
first author
publication. This is six to nine first author publication,
and then 10 plus
first author application. So I just want to point it out that I don't want
you to go away with...
Sometimes quality play a bit bigger role than quantity.
So this here, K08, 60% has more than 10
plus application, butClinicians
tend to have a lot more, first off, the publication in clinical
observation, not necessarily the research.
So
just bear in mind. So what helped you with your
application? You heard Mark mention something.
So you have to be responsive to the NOFO.
Okay, so what does the program announcement say?
What are they looking for? Then you have to be careful with it.
So then the section five of the NOFO, it tells you
score review criteria. So it has bullet points, and then you go there, what
are the reviewers looking for? So you want to make sure the
information's in your application.
So
because these awards are career development, we hope that you
become independent researchers.
So you have to demonstrate that you are ready and committed to
become an independent researcher.
And then also, because it's a career development, in your application, you have
to put what type of skill gap and knowledge gap that you try
to fulfill during
five years of award. So you have to include didactic coursework, workshops,
technical skill development.
And then your research. Your research has to be innovative.
And
so, what
type of researches do better? You have to have a
high scientific merit and robust, unbiased approaches in your research
strategy, hypothesis-driven, mechanistic-driven approaches do
well, better, because there's a sustainability.
And you have to demonstrate that whatever approach that you put it in, it has
that feasibility. And then you provide
alternative approaches. If your proposed this
one approach doesn't work, how are you going to approach it?
So the application has to be well-structured.
And then you have to have a good mentoring team.
So when you select the mentor,
mentor has to have a skill set that complement to your proposal.
If mentors are not expert in the field that you want to do, then
you should not. It doesn't matter, it's a great guy,
great scientist, but they don't have expertise that you are trying
to
obtain, then you
won't do well. So you have to have
the right mentoring teams. Okay, and then also mentor has to
have a training track record. They know how to train a
postdoc to become independent researchers. So those help.
And then your strong institutional support.
Institutional will give you, yes, you have a nine calendar month to do the
research, and then they will provide all the facility, and
sometime
some institution will provide you for a sudden amount of dollars to
do your research. So those are needed.
So again, here is the mailbox. It's very simplified.
So if you are interested in K99, you put NCI K99 NIH,
and whoever the program director assigned to the
mechanism will respond to you. So with that. Okay.
So, I'm going to be at the NCI booth on Monday,
12:30 to 1:30, Tuesday, 12:30 to 2:30.
And then on Tuesday, again, at 3:00, I'll be giving a talk about
T32, which is the institutional training grants.
So with that, thank you.
All right. Hi, everybody. My name is Kelly Crotty, and now I'm going to talk to you
about the R50 program for lab and core-based specialists.
And then you're going to hear about another R50 program from Wolf for clinician
scientists. So I have nothing to disclose.
So the R50 is a grant mechanism to support specialists in
cores and laboratories. And this is to encourage the development of stable
career opportunities for people in these positions in full-time,
non-tenure track research positions.
This is a five-year award that will cover the salary of the specialist
for the amount of time that they're spending on NCI-funded research.
And they need to be spending the majority of their time, so this would be between 6
and 12 months of salary, plus funds for travel, doing
trainings, and so forth. And the purpose of the R50 is really
to provide competitive salaries and sufficient independence for people
in these positions to make it an attractive and sustainable career path.
So who is the research specialists?
These are highly trained, exceptional scientists who want to pursue a
research career but not be independent
investigators. They're providing stability, expertise, and
technical excellence to strengthen the cancer research infrastructure.
And unlike trainees who turn over very quickly, the students and postdocs
are in time-limited positions, staff scientists and research
specialists are providing long-term expertise to preserve
institutional knowledge and support collaborations.
The program that I administer supports research specialists both in individual
research labs as well as those who are working within core facilities or
shared resources and supporting multiple laboratories within the
institution.
There are very specific eligibility requirements for these funding
opportunities to make sure that the applicants are the people that we're intending
to support here. So the applicant must have an advanced degree, a
master's, a PhD, an MD, and demonstrated professional
accomplishments in cancer research that's consonant with the level of experience
they have. And so the R50 supports people who are fairly new to the
position, as well as people who have been a staff scientist
for a longer amount of time. They must be in full-time,
non-tenure track research positions.
And this is not for people who are in training positions.
So you've heard about a lot of mechanisms to support people who do eventually
intend to be an independent investigator.
But the R50 is for people who want to be in this
position as their career path. So they also should not have
held or applied for independent investigator support within the last
five years.They need to have been contributing to
the cancer research program where they're working for at least two years, and at
least six months of their time, at least half their time, needs to be
spent on NCI-funded research.
The application also needs to identify the unit director, who's the independent
investigator who has the NCI grants that the research
specialist is working on. And then in the application, the unit director will
provide a letter of support to describe how the specialist is important
to their research program,
demonstrate a commitment to the specialist's career, and also show
the NCI grants that the specialist is spending their time on, as well as show
that they have continued funding to support the specialist, as the
R50 covers the salary but doesn't cover the actual research
activities. So the unit director needs to continue to cover the research
activities through their NCI grants.
There's a lot of unique application and review requirements because
this is to support the salary of somebody, not their research
activities. And so in the application, the research strategy is really
focused on who the specialist is and how they are uniquely
contributing to the research program.
So there's no specific aims, and they're not proposing new research activities.
The budget request can include salary as well as funds for travel and training
activities. And, as I mentioned, there needs to be a letter of support from the
unit director, as well as three more letters of support from other
investigators who can attest to the specialist's expertise and
contributions. The review is also very different
because the reviewers are not evaluating a research plan.
They're evaluating how important this person is to the research
program. So they're going to be considering, does the specialist have
important experience, training, and accomplishments?
How are they contributing to the research program where they work?
Is the specialist developing new approaches?
Are they contributing new research directions?
Some tips for building a strong application for the R50 is to
focus on the specialist's past, present, and future contributions to
the research program. So again, they're not proposing new research, so you should
not be providing aims of what's going to happen over
those five years, but talk about how this research specialist is
an integral part of the research program.
And the contributions of the specialist should go beyond just
performing experiments. So specialists are more than technicians.
They should also be contributing new research ideas or hypotheses,
developing or adapting new technologies, training people within the lab
or within the labs that they support, maintaining or initiating
collaborations, and improving rigor and reproducibility in cancer research
by establishing standardized protocols.
And the unique background training and expertise of the specialist should be
described, which supports the value of all of these activities that
they perform.
You should also describe the career goals and aspirations of the specialist.
So again, this should be their research or their career path, so you should not be
proposing becoming an independent investigator eventually.
The specialist should reassert their commitment to this career path,
but then also talk about how they're going to remain cutting edge,
and any aspirations to become a recognized expert in their field, joining a
society, maybe becoming an officer of a relevant society someday.
So we are hoping to have some forecasts for new R50 funding
opportunities out soon. But in the meantime, feel free to reach out to me if you
have questions or would like updates, or if you're thinking that this might be a
good mechanism to support you or someone in your lab. Thank you.
Okay.
Here we are.
All right, thank you all for sticking with us all this time.
So I'm going to describe our other R50 program, which is for clinician
scientists.
And I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So this is going to be a really different population of scientists that
we're
targeting with this program. You've heard about things like the K08 for clinician
scientists. NCI has traditionally not had
extended funding throughout the career
stages for individuals who want to focus on clinical trials and not
have their own independent research program beyond the early
career. So that's what this R50 is intended to fill, this particular funding
gap.
So it provides a career path and stable salary support for
clinician scientists who want to focus on the design and conduct of
NCI-funded clinical trials but who do not seek independent research
funding from grants like R01s and other similar
research grants.
It's intended to promote their retention in this career path.
These are individuals with significant relevant experience and
a record of productivity and research excellence in the
implementation of these clinical trials.
So what kind of activities are the R50 PIs
performing?
Accrual to NCI-sponsored clinical trials,
development of clinical trials within our national clinical trial networks,
leadership in those networks, leadership in NCI scientific steering committees,
and being national or site PI of NCI-funded clinical
trials and other similar activities.
They also provide service and leadership within their institute,
in their clinical trials infrastructure, and leadership within their
institution's disease or modality-based groups.
So to be eligible, you need to have a clinical degree, such as an MD,
and be actively practicing in the oncology setting.
You can also have a PhD or other
doctoral degree with direct contactWith patients in
fields such as clinical psychology, nursing, et cetera.
The applicant needs to have a full-time position and has been at
their current institution for at least two years.
But, so again, this is aimed at mid to late career stage.
They have to be in their initial faculty appointment.
They need to be six years out from that initial faculty appointment.
They have to have a record of involvement in and are currently engaged in NCI
funded cancer clinical trials research.
And they cannot be the PI of current R01, P01, or other significant
NIH funding.
And, again, this is intended to fill a gap.
This is not for people who already have funding from other sources.
So total NCI support from any type of grants cannot exceed
50% time.
It's open to all US institutions that are either academic medical
centers or community sites.
And each one of those centers can only apply
for four R50 awards per year.
The budget supports between 20% and 40% effort.
This is effectively protected time for the investigator to
perform the activities that I described.
Just keep in mind that most of these folks are performing clinical service
within their institution. They're seeing patients.
The institutions are depending on them to generate income for their institution.
What we are doing is giving them protected time to work on
clinical trials.
And there's also a small travel stipend.
Sorry, went backwards.
What are folks saying about this award? So here's a few awardees.
"I've been able to reduce my clinical practice to focus more on clinical trials
implementation and treating patients primarily on trials, and the R50 has
strengthened my efforts to accelerate drug development through national trials at
my institution as well as in the region."
Another PI said, "The R50 has been a defining opportunity for my own
career development to date. It will continue to shape my career trajectory as I
look to grow in leadership and contribution in support of NCI funded clinical
trials.
With reduced pressure on clinical productivity, I've been able to deepen my
involvement in biomarker development and explore innovative clinical trial
strategies.
The R50 allowed me to expand our local trial participation, leading to my
appointment as institutional leader for SWOG." It's one of the cooperative
groups. "A role that would not have been possible without this support."
And I'm sure many of our other PIs would say very similar things.
So,
we have a common email box for the R50s. You can contact us.
Be great if you put in the subject line whether you're looking for the clinical one
or for the lab and core, because they're quite different.
But we're happy to answer any questions.
Have a little bookmark with a QR code if you want to scan that,
or if you just want it for posterity's sake.
We are hoping to have our forecast out
this year, so please look for it, and we're hoping to have an FOA as well,
because there are currently no active opportunities.
So thank you.
So, thanks so much for your attention during the
session. We're glad to take questions.
There are individuals participating online, so if you could please use the
microphones that are in the center of the room.
If you forget, I'll repeat your question.
But
please let us know your name, where you're from, and then what your
question is about.
Go ahead.
Hey, thanks for presenting all this.
I've dealt with some of you, and you've been very supportive on numerous grant
applications, so I appreciate you personally and also in general in
terms of supporting the research enterprise.
I had a question about the K32. My name is Tim Trish.
I'm at the Van Andel Institute. I currently have a graduate student who's an
F99K00 scholar with the NCI, and
my understanding is that the K32 was meant to subsume the
F99K00. What is the status of that mechanism?
K32, it is a focus, but we're still waiting for the
approval, so we don't know. We hope it will be published
next month, but we don't know.
Cool. Thank you very much.
Can I clarify? Actually, you indicated that it's supposed to subsume the
F99K00.
Yeah.
So
the F99K00 is intended to be published-
Okay
... as a mechanism.
So what's the relationship between those mechanisms?
So, no, K32, I think it's more like a F32.
Right.
It is for the early career stage.
Mm-hmm.
Like two years, with less than two years of post-doctorate
experience. There's no transition part.
So it is more like F32 than F99.
Oh, okay. So the F99K00 is going to stick around in its current form indefinitely
as far as anybody knows?
We hope so.
Okay, cool.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Julie. I'm at Harvard, graduating in a month.
My question was for the K99. You showed the rates around,
I think, 20-ish percent of acceptance.
Do you have those rates by US citizenship or not?
Or is it similar for international versus-
No, I don't have it top of my head.
Okay. Thank you.
But if you need it, send the email to us and we may be able to provide you with
what
you need.
Okay. And the second question is, so when you were talking about the mentor,
having the mentor clearly be someone who's proficient in the field,
et cetera, do they need to be at the same institution that you are,
or can they be in a different institution?
For K99, all the career development award is a mentor
award. So, reviewer like to see mentor next
door to you, accessible to you. But you could have some
co-mentors that with the expertise that you don't have it at your institution,
you can have them. But yes, then
if you have a mentor outside your university,
you might have to put detail how you're going to interact, how accessible that
mentor is to you. So, those information were
needed.
Yeah.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Hi. So thank you again for this opportunity to have this session for us.
It's really helpful.
So I have two questions. One is regarding the K08.
What stage are they usually at for this opportunity?
Is it usually fellows, or do they have to be faculty at that stage?
So I manage the K08, so I can answer the question.
So K08, I've seen,
well, they call it post-doc, but could be
instructor apply.
Okay.
Or it could be assistant professor apply.
It's depending on the discipliner.
So usually after the fellowship training-
Yes
... they apply.
Yes.
Okay. And then the other question is for the K32.
I realize this is newer, but are other institutes
co-opting this mechanism, or is it just NCI right now?
No, just NCI.
No, actually,
so there's six institutes-
Oh, okay
... that are going to be on it. I can't name them off the top of my head, but-
Perfect. That's great.
Yes.
I'll keep an eye out. Thank you.
Hi.
My question is about the pre-doctoral awards.
So I was wondering, in terms of specifics,
what have you guys found that ends up being the strongest predictor for successful
applications?
Actually, what you're thinking about here when you're preparing your application is
that this is a training award, okay?
And reviewers are looking for ... Everybody thinks
about their research, the research plan and things like that, and
that's all great. Everyone wants to see you doing good
research, well thought out, and all of that stuff.
But the important thing is to think about everything in your application,
including your research plan, in terms of how is it going to get me to
my next stage? How is it helping me to train to get
from here to there?
So you're talking more about what am I going to learn from this?
What can I take home from this
research plan?
What is my mentor doing for me? Why is this the best mentor for me?
Why is this institution the best place for me to be?
What are they providing me that will help to train me?
As a lot of people always say, "Well, it's not all about you."
Yes, it is. It's all about you. Okay?
You want to think about that as you're preparing your application.
Every last bit of it is about you. How are you going to get from where you are now
to where you want to go?
And so the people who do the best job of that are the people who get funded,
because that's what reviewers are tasked with finding.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi, this is Ray from UCLA. I have a question regarding K08.
Do we have an estimated
award percentage this year, next physical year?
And then a second question is,
if you get a K08 award, and then
for different reasons, you
go to a different institution, then how does that work out? Thank you.
No, I don't have information for this year award yet because the
fiscal year is still in the run, so we don't
have the final numbers.
We like to fund as many as we can with the budget that we
have. So we hope to keep the success
rate in 20%. But then every year, the number
application going up, the budget stay the same, so you
will see the numbers remain still or
lower.
Second questions? Oh.
Was changing institutions.
Transfer. We say transfer is not automatic.
A lot of people think they
will submit the progress report for this year, and then a
week after that, they say, "Oh, I'm moving to another institute."
They think that the check or whatever money will go.
It's an administrative review.
I haven't seen any transfer
declined or terminated, but we have to
review it. For example, if you have an animal
or a human subject, we have to make sure that you have those assurance at
the new institution. So we do administrative
review for the K08 change of
institution or transfer. But just
submit the application as soon as you know that you're taking the job there.
Because it takes six weeks for us at least to review and all the
process. So,
yeah. We
are here to help you.
So we're out of time.
Okay.
And I just want to make sure,
do we have the room for a couple more minutes where we can take a couple more
questions? Okay. Yeah.
Hello, I'm Tiffan from Montana. I have a question for R50.
We are starting to develop
a
core for AI and electronic medical record.
And we plan more like
50% of this development, and also try to do
independent research.
Is R25 going to work? Or because it's
new, so there are no
paths
that are not too much present, and there are also this uncertainty
of funding and approach and yeah.
Yeah.
I think this is aUnique situation, so definitely
reach out to me and I can help advise on that.
Usually, you need to have been working at that institution, contributing to the
program for at least two years before you apply, because the
reviewers do want to see, do you have a track record of success?
Yeah.
And so if it's completely new, they can
still see, have you been at the institution for a while?
Have you been contributing to the program?
Yeah.
But another key eligibility is that it's being NCI funded.
And so that's the other part of it, is the research specialist's salary
coming from NCI grants? And then the amount of salary that's been coming from
grants is the amount that the R50 will start covering instead.
But I'm happy to talk more about-
Okay
... that situation.
Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah.
A question in the back.
Yeah. So Rajagopal Ramesh from the University of Oklahoma Health Sciences Center.
A quick question. So
on the slide presentation, you were showing a K43.
Never heard about it, and didn't hear anything about the K43.
K32, you mean?
No, 43. Yeah, there's a T32, but in the K43, there was a slide, I think the
picture-
Oh.
Yeah. But I-
So it's a K program that's run through the Fogarty International
Center at NIH.
So
the individual who knows a lot about that is Sudha Srivaram in the
Center for Global Health.
Thank you.
Yes.
Thanks.
Hi. Sorry. I'm too small. So my name is Mariana.
I'm from Northwestern. And I know that you no longer have
a K22. So is a K01 like
a replacement? I know it's not the same mechanism, but would
it be like an equivalent to a K22?
No. You say you are asking whether K01 is equivalent to K22?
Yeah, because I applied for a K22, and I know
I cannot resubmit. I applied for a
K99, and I think I'm not eligible anymore.
Well, okay, how many years of postdoctoral experience?
Because K99 used to be up to four years of postdoc, so we
extend it to a six year.
It will be soon six years-
Oh
... but I finished my PhD
before that.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure if I'm still eligible,
so that's why I'm wondering if I should apply for a K01.
Yeah. I guess currently we don't have anything the equivalent to
K22, but contact the K99 PD, and they
will look at your biosketch, and they could give you a better answers.
Thank you.
So we'll take two more questions, and then we'll stay in the room, and we'll be
here to answer questions, but we'll just end the session. And you can come up.
Go ahead.
My question to Kelly, and I'm a unit director in the sense of the
R50 grant, so I'm a PA of the lab. And my fellow applied, and
we got couple of comments, and none of them are really valid in our view.
And one of the comment is the innovative aspect, and
they say it's the incremental, the science is
incremental.
And from your description and also from the scope of the program, I
understand this doesn't really have to be innovative.
So I'm wondering how to address these
kind of two things, incremental and innovative.
So thank you.
Yeah. So for the R50, we think about innovation in terms
of,
does this person bring a new perspective to the
research program? Are they bringing something to the research program that nobody
else could really bring? And allowing research to happen that
without them there,
the lab wouldn't be moving in that direction, right?
They're really providing something unique.
So you're right that the reviewers should not be evaluating the research
itself, because that's already NCI funded.
It's already been reviewed and funded.
They should really be focusing on the role of that person.
So I'm happy to talk a little bit more about that specific summary statement and go
through it. And I will say that the R50 is
very competitive. We have similar success rates, around 20%,
but the scores tend to be very, very good.
And so even something that gets really, really good
scores sometimes doesn't get funded, and it's just because it's a very
competitive program.
Okay. And this RFA will be open again?
We're hoping to have a forecast out soon. Yeah.
Okay.
With a NOFO later this year.
Oh, okay. Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay, last question on the mic.
Hey.
Thank you so much for this session.
This is Reza from University of Iowa, and I'm a third-year
PhD student.
So as an international student, I was interested to apply for
F99K00. But in the criteria
eligibility, I saw that US citizenship is required.
So my question is, I can't remember from the last year that was
actually international students on F1 visa also.
Yeah, I can answer that. So that's unfortunately been a change that's
occurred with the program within NIH just in this past year.
Okay.
So although the funding opportunity hasn't been published yet, there is a
forecast for it. Instead of an NCI
funding opportunity, it's going to be an NIH-wide parent funding opportunity,
and NIH
has determined that the citizenship eligibility is a
requirement-
Okay
... for F99K00.
Okay. Then the next question would be, can I apply
without green card and then
for getting that funding, if I'm approved?
Yes. You don't have to have the citizenship to apply-
Like study-wide, right?
... but to receive the award. Right.
For all of these awards-
Okay
... that we talked about,
or except for the R50, there's no citizenship requirement.
But yes, as long as by the time of award.
And sometimes
an individual may not have received their green card by the time of the
award. There have been instances that I've seen where maybe you can request to
defer the award for up to six months, depending what's going
on with the
citizenship.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
All right. Thank you so much for joining our session.
Please come up to us and ask individual questions or email us. Thanks a lot.